Ласкаво просимо до програми У фокусі
Європа Ми раді що ви з нами
пардуган домінує турецькій політиці вже
понад 20 років але тепер йому не
вистачило абсолютно більшості на
президентських виборах
уперше за два десятиліцію Йому
доведеться зіткнутися з другим туром
виборів
вже святкують перемогу
на цих президентських виборах партія
ердогана псс решла нога в ногу з
опозицією
багато Турків хочуть мати більше
демократії і лідеропозиції який мав
келич даругло обіцяє саме це
майже 90% Турків проголосували на цих
виборах із невеликою перевагою
прихильники ердогана бачать себе на крок
ближчими до перемоги вони не хочуть
жодних змін Очевидно вони вірять що
Президент впорається з поганою
економічною ситуацією подбає про
відновлення якого Україна терміново
потребує після землетрусів
з іншого боку опоненти звинувачують його
в кризі яку переживає країна
джинсує півча вирішила не голосувати за
ердогана Вона боїться за свою матір яка
знаходиться у в'язниці через критику
ердогана а свобода її матері здається
повністю залежить від зміни влади в
країні
Стамбул після першого туру
президентських виборів незважаючи на те
що президент Туреччини не отримав
абсолютної більшості голосів прихильники
реджепу та її пр догана задоволені
Це була Воля народу
у стамбульському мистецькому кварталі
кузгунчук настрої зовсім інші
після позитивних прогнозів для опозиції
більшість людей тут сподіваються на
зміну уряду і новий напрямок для
Туреччини
вони покладають свої надії на другий тур
виборів
другий тур голосування Боже але я вірю
що в нас є шанс і сподіваюся що ми все ж
зможемо його реалізувати Нам доведеться
знову закатати рукава тому що ми хочемо
нарешті жити у вільній демократичній
країні Де кожен почувається у безпеці
Джансу Я п'юче вже давно бореться за
демократичну Туреччину разом зі своєю
матір'ю Ну челлею я п'юча яка вже більше
року знаходиться у в'язниці її засудили
до 18 років ув'язнення за звинуваченням
у сприянні спробі державного перевороту
давай вперед
[оплески]
ішли ділянку
архітекторкам на цьому знімку вона разом
зі своєю донькою під час винесення
вироку виступала за соціальну забудову
міст яка була б сейсмостійкою і брала
участь у протесному русі у
стамбульському парку газі мені особливо
подобається ця фотографія з в'язниці на
ній моя мама така спокійна і водночас
сильна
Влада за проторила мою маму за ґрати щоб
залякати інших активістів
Але чи бачите ви на цій фотографії
налякану жінку
сім'ї цих політичних в'язнів у Туреччині
покладають Надії на кандидати від
опозиції
кемаль киличдар оглу пообіцяв
звільнитимучило є пюча та інших якщо він
переможе на виборах
за останній рік Ми пройшли через
емоційні Американські гірки
те що доля моєї матері та інших
ув'язнених залежить від результату цих
виборів лише показує наскільки все в
Туреччині погано
Вона часто ходить до моря щоб
відволіктися але здаватися не збирається
як і її мати вона теж архітекторка і вже
багато років займається питаннями прав
жінок
але державні репресії та ворожнечі з
боку про урядових ЗМІ даються знаки
вже давно не відчуваю що мені раді в цій
країні
за таких умов важко продовжувати жити як
зазвичай
зараз вона записалася спостерігачем на
вибори і прагне переконатися що все
пройде без проблем під час другого туру
виборів майже 90% виборців які мають
право голосу проголосували у першому
Турі
другий тур вважається вирішальним багато
Турків незадоволені
катастрофічно-економічною ситуацією
провальною реакцію уряду на землетруси
та утисками фундаментальних прав
зрештою саме Солідарність між усіма нами
небажаними в цій країні змушує нас іти
вперед і зберігає нам життя
вона каже що Солідарність між
демократами потрібна зараз більше ніж
будь-коли другий тур виборів може стати
останнім шансом на свободу для її матері
мітчеллияюче
ердоган колись починав як реформатор але
потім він пішов далі збільшуючи свою
владу і за 21 рік став настільки
могутнім що засоби масової інформації в
країні Не можуть висвітлювати події ні
незалежно ні критично як Ми щойно
побачили ті хто наважується висловлювати
свою думку можуть опинитися у в'язниці
при арт-доганні Туреччина стає все
більше авторитарною консервативною і
патріархальною дамла даглаян добре знає
як це жінки особливо страждають від
режиму ердогана вони майже не отримують
жодного захисту від держави ця молода
турецька жінка сподівається що її Країна
зміниться
заняття у стамбульському університеті де
23-річна дамла вивчає політологію
закінчилися
Вона приїжджає сюди у район фатіх щодня
це традиційно-мусульманський район
вони витріщаються на мене незалежно від
того показує є живіт чи прикриває його
вони витріщаються мені тут не комфортно
і моїм друзям теж
після занять дамла повертається на інший
кінець міста у модний і сучасний
і там зустрічається із другом жінка каже
що у кадике почувається вільнішою Але й
тут усе змінюється особливо після того
як Туреччина вийшла зі стамбульської
Конвенції про запобігання насильство
щодо жінок
активісти руху за права жінок кажуть що
в Туреччині щодня вбивають щонайменше
одну жінку а незліченна кількість інших
зазнає домашнього насильства та домагань
Я думаю що кожна 20-річна жінка в цій
країні стикалася з домаганнями
про це мало говорять але це трапляється
в автобусах спільних таксі на поромах
зі мною це теж траплялося
положення стамбульської конвенції все ще
закріплені у національному законодавстві
але нові ультра ісламіські коаліційні
партнери президента
ердогана закликають до обмеження прав
жінок
ба більше Вони вимагають роздільних
класів для хлопчиків і дівчаток і
покарання за перелюбство
[музика]
шокує
це не можна описати інакше вони хочуть
щоб чоловіки вирішували все А жінки не
мали ніяких прав деякі тварини мають
більше прав ні жінки Уявіть собі
за кілька кілометрів звідси знаходиться
офіс жіночої партії кадін партісі
вони висунули звинувачення проти
керівників партії партнера пср із
ісламіської коаліції або не хочуть
заснувати ісламську республіку навіть не
зважаючи на те що Туреччина рухається до
того аби стати сучасною країною зараз у
рік сторіччя свого заснування це
неприйнятно їхні звинувачення нікуди не
дійшли
жіноча партія частина опозиції але
навіть жінки політики із пср критикують
вимогу скасувати закон про захист жінок
як наприклад узлом гін старший радниця
президента рдогана
на це за свої особисті Свободи
тим часом дамла завершує день зі своєю
подругою IQ ойки працює офіціанткою але
шукає роботу журналісткою
26-річну дівчину роками переслідує її
колишній хлопець
востаннє це було 3-4 тижні тому ми
випадково зіткнулися Він погрозливо
подивився на мене і сказав я тебе бачу і
кілька разів пройшовся переді мною
туди-сюди
Я чесно кажучи боюся бачитися з ним я
дуже непокоїюся
поки що він не вдавався до насильства
але чотири з 10 жінок у Туреччині
зазнають фізичного або сексуального
насильства з боку своїх партнерів
це вдвічі більше ніж у Німеччині
правозахисні організації кажуть що
турецька Влада часто ігнорує
повідомлення про домагання або
насильство IQ неодноразово заявляла про
свого колишнього в поліцію але марно
ми всі хочемо мислити позитивно але нас
молодих людей охоплює якась безнадія
Я хочу щоб у майбутньому Туреччина стала
безпечною країною для жінок і дівчат
я цією ж думки
Ось чому ця патріархальна система має
змінитися
демократичне майбутнє у якому всі голоси
будуть почуті
за вільно Туреччину
дамла і IQ схрещують пальці щоб другий
тур виборів змінив ситуацію для них Якщо
цього не станеться багато молодих турків
уже думають про виїзд з країни перейдемо
до іншої держави де люди були змушені
покинути свою країну до України
Важко уявити але навіть у найгарячіших
точках на сході України деякі цивільні
прийняли свідоме рішення залишитися
української поліції намагаються
дістатися до цих людей переконати їх
покинути територію
але їм це дається нелегко адже в таких
містах яка вдіївка та Вздовж лінії
фронту на Сході України деякі люди
відчувають зв'язок з Росією
Авдіївка - це Україна написано на
табличці здається цілком зрозуміло які
настрої тут у людей і все ж у таких
префентових містечках як це ми знаходимо
більш складні історії
Ці чоловіки Геннадій і Дмитро входять до
евакуаційного підрозділу поліції який
прозвали білими ангелами
залишатись в крайній небезпечна це
працюють один магазин де можна придбати
і хліб сам поход до магазину або за
водою або за ліками або в лікарню це
квест пройдеш не пройдеш виживеш не
виживеш можна попати під обстріл і либо
отримати поранення либо загинути
до війни тут мешкало понад 32 тисячі
людей бомби і снаряди досі падають сюди
російські війська досягають певних
успіхів але незначних
і все ж близько 2 000 людей вирішили
залишитися
у цьому розподільчому пункті пропонують
чай електрику і компанію
тут моя Батьківщина я тут Народилась я
тут усе життя прожила тут Мої батьки
лежать у землі Я не хочу покидати свій
дім
браття двох поколінь просто зруйнована
Мені дуже шкода але це сильніше за мене
Я не можу поїхати
Геннадія та Дмитра попросили відвідати
одну подружню пару
донька цього чоловіка попросила
поліцейських вивести їх звідти вони
прибралися під землю
ваша ваша донька надіслала нам
відеозапис
просила щоб ви переглянули його
Привіт так продовжуватись більше не може
я не можу дозволити щоб мій рідний
єдиний батько жив у таких умовах Богом
молю дуже надіюся і чекаю на тебе цілую
обіймаю ваша донька Миколайович Ви
готові виїхати ні чого вони ж готові вас
прихистити донька ж прийме вас я не
готовий чому А коли будете готові
Скажіть коли все це закінчиться
страх паралізує якщо тобі суджено від
цього загинути Ти загинеш якщо ні то ні
я наприклад боюся дороги мені все
здається що в дорозі зі мною Щось
трапиться
Геннадій і Дмитро не можуть примусово
вивозити людей російська пропаганда
змусила декого боятися українською влади
мовляємо даємо час на градум’я людям ми
їх вивозимо на броньований автомобіль до
Покровська де їх приймуть волонтери
оформлять пенсію а оформлять
переселенців
все буде них добре В самому місці
Ми змушені припинити зйомки і знайти
укриття
щойно стало безпечно ми йдемо туди де
впала бомба
Це був міський ринок
Ця жінка прийшла продавати товари для
дому
вона не постраждала але явно у шоці
Авдіївка була прифронтовим містом
задовго до повномасштабного російського
вторгнення у 2014 році бойовики яких
підтримувала Росія контролювали місто
короткий період часу перш ніж українці
повернули його дехто досі ідентифікує
себе з росіянами незважаючи на війну
за годину їзди у часовому яру ми
наближаємося до бахмута
вважається що тут залишилося менше 10%
населення
тут Ми зустрічаємо Олега йому 74 роки
раніше він був економістом
зараз він вирощує цибулю зараз битими
вікнами
Не хочеться
нікуди їхати Я тут народився довго
прожив тут мої батьки були Я не хочу
їхати від їхніх могил краще помру тут і
тут буду похований Не бійтеся це від нас
стріляють
ми просимо його показати нам якийсь
спогад щось довоєнне він дістає це
радянський військовий квиток 43-річної
давнини але завжди під рукою
мені і тих Дурнів і цих шкода це один
народ Одні ті самі люди розумієте
вони всі були в Радянському Союзі всі
служили в Радянській армії колись а
зараз розділилися думки
для начальство десь неправильно щось
зробило що зіштовхнуло один Народ не
треба було так робити Розумієте треба
було домовлятися
це поширені настрої у таких містах як це
навіть незважаючи на те що перемовини
можуть означати життя під владою Москви
виглядає так ніби дехто не лише
ностальгує за радянським союзом але
чекає на прихід росіян
підрозділ за напрямками авдіївці ми
запитали в офіцера Геннадія про це
на жаль є такі випадки які є чекають так
званого руського миру
можливо і зливають інформацію розташонки
збройних сил України є такі випадки коли
затримували Службу безпеки України таких
людей
є такий
у которых місцевих мешканців воюють на
той стороні родичі
офіцери білих ангелів приїхали Щоб
запропонувати виїзд із міста для всіх
Хто готовий їхати
для сільського господарства важливо мати
багато води але в Європі літо з кожним
роком стає все сухішими сухіше і Франція
одна з країни яка особливо страждає від
цього
фермер реміл оренду також турбований
посухою але він усе ж виступає проти
планів французького уряду збирати дощову
воду величезних об'ємах і він не один
такий на заході Франції в селі сенсолін
фермер борються заводу
наприкінці березня конфлікт навколо
мегабасейну у сенсуліні загострився
кілька тисяч демонстрантів вийшли на
поля і поліція намагалася їх стримати у
хід пішли сльозогінний газ фаєри каміння
і були серйозні поранення і з обох
сторін
протести стосувалося цього будівництва
тут влада будує величезне водосховище
для дощової води яке буде
використовуватися для поливу у літні
місяці
у селі сенсулін проживає 300 жителів і
вони розділилися на два табори навколо
цього питання
Артур перо один із фермерів які
підтримують проект
він вже облаштував своє підключення до
басейну
ми захистили його перед демонстрацією ми
зробили навіс і використовували солому
дошки і землю щоб накрити все це
Вони знали де було сполучення усе це
спалили
перо має 170 гектарів землі на яких
вирощує переважно пшеницю і кукурудзу
культури які не можуть вижити без
додаткового зрошення
реміл оренду також фермер але він проти
водосховища Він має три гектари землі і
в основному вирощує овочі у нього своя
власна криниця
вода впала порівняно з тим що було два
тижні тому
у звичайний рік Вона переповнюється
взимку
А зараз вода впала щонайменше на 2 метри
[музика]
Він боїться що його криниця може
пересохнути якщо дощова вода більше не
буде просочуватися У грунтові води а
буде збиратися у басейні
я не матиму до неї доступу у мене не так
багато землі тому немає фінансового
сенсу проводити водогін це мало б сенс
лише Якби я використовував певний об'єм
води
люди які не займаються сільським
господарством бояться опинитися між
двома фронтами
якщо ви послухаєте тих хто за У них є
чудовий аргументи так само як у тих хто
проти Я визнаю що в мене немає чіткої
думки
Це величезне будівництво для 12 людей
для мене це фактично приватизація
ці люди збираються монополізувати
частину води
[музика]
такі водосховища будуються по всій
Франції за вказівкою з Парижа і не всі
цим задоволенням
[музика]
кліматичні активісти Кажуть що немає
сенсу відводити воду якої так не
вистачає І що краще було б перейти на
менш водовідтрат на сільське
господарство
журналіст Марк ломацький побоюються що
конфлікт навколо води буде тільки
загострюватися і торкнеться не лише
сільського господарства
лінзи лише початок того що буде
відбуватися у Франції оскільки Вода стає
все більш дефіцитною
у нас буде дефіцит у нас буде нормування
води не вистачить на всіх
овочевий фермер лорандо теж хоче щоб
проект зупинили але він занепокоєний
жорстокістю протестів у березні
не можна сказати що це була війна але
майже так
я не можу поїхати до сенсу Ліну через
протести
бо вони надто бурхливі
перо теж стурбований ескалацією але він
не бачить виходу із ситуації на даний
момент
діалогу більше немає
говорити з людьми які кажуть що хочуть
говорити але тільки за умови що ти
поважатимеш те що вони хочуть робити
[музика]
сенсулін лише один з прикладів багатьох
розділених громад у Центральній та
південній Франції
коли цього літа настане спека боротьба
за воду ймовірно посилиться
[музика]
ви можете вважати кіз не найрозумнішими
істотами але зовнішність може бути
оманливою
насправді кози одні з цих тварин що
відчувають наближення стихійних лих
наприклад виверження вулкана чи
землетрусом
саме тому дослідники на Сицилії біля
підніжжя вулкана Етна розробляють
систему раннього попередження і з
допомогою кіз
якщо це дійсно працює Ми можливо Будемо
бачити більше кіз навколо нас а на
сьогодні це все ми повернемось за
тиждень Бережіть себе і до зустрічі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]